inflation is a wild subject while once
considered almost universally bad high
rates of inflation have now hit america
and countries with very different
reactions than i'm used to coming from
media outlets it's a bit like the
pandemic actually some say it doesn't
exist some say it's transitory and it'll
go away by itself while most people
think having a lot of it around is gonna
be really bad for us we're inviting on
the finance channel tom nash aka mr
bearmarket uh let me just ask you
inflation a big deal should we be
worried about it well let me tell you a
little story
when i was 15 i had a toothache
and i ignored it for like seven years
and what ended up happening is that the
tooth was in such a bad shape
i was screaming for my mom and more in
aesthetics and eventually we resolved
this issue
the dentist needed the
treatment but
it's like neglecting your teeth
when you neglect inflation you run the
risks of
experiencing immense amount of pain and
long-lasting damage
which is exactly where we at right now
only problem is we have a very strange
situation where
we went to the doctor he told us our
teeth are fine he asked that we paid the
bill for for his services we paid the
bill and now he called us to say well in
fact i was wrong your teeth are
completely [ __ ] the minute he got her
money which is uh wait obviously wait
hold on let's play fair uh obviously
you're talking about our supreme leader
jerome powell no no no no i would never
how dare you doubt him such a cynical
such a cynical person
without jp
look i wanna this is actually why i
wanted to bring this all up is because
i've been watching with some interest
sort of the media cycle around this
trying to figure out what what's going
on how to feel about it and it's been
interesting to watch it feels like the
five stages of grief but with inflation
realizing that it is happening at first
they said inflation will not happen you
know it's not going to happen we're
going to be fine and then jerome powell
told us it's transitory in the end it
will be transitory and uh people need to
have faith in the central bank that we
that we will do that but we won't do it
just because you know we honestly it
would be a mistake to do it at a time
when we really do believe and virtually
all forecasters do believe that these
things will come down of their own
accord as the economy reopens so there
you go we just need to all have faith
and everything will be fine but then
eventually he told us that well that's
not what he meant by transitory things
aren't coming down the concept of
transitory is really this
it is that uh
the increases
will happen
we're not saying they will reverse
that's not what transitory means it
means that the increases in prices will
happen so there will be inflation but
that the process of inflation will stop
so okay now it's just gonna stop all on
its own but now he says we need to
retire the term transitory altogether
even though he's the one who invented it
how long does inflation have to run
above your target before the fed decides
maybe it's not so transitory i think
it's it's probably a good time to retire
that that word and try to explain more
clearly what we mean so tom this is my
conundrum i'm trying to understand what
jerome powell means when he's talking
about inflation it's not here it's
transitory white that's not what we
meant wait it's not transitory it's here
to stay are we facing an inflation
crisis and what's really going on here
explain to us what's going on well
stephen i think the problem is with you
your cynicism does not allow you to
appreciate the full scope of jerome
powell's explanation let me explain to
you what's going on please and i know
some of you cynical people will say well
it's really ironic it's like the common
is saying let's retire the word stalin
right it's pretty much he's the one who
came up with the term and now he's
retiring it i think it's only fair it's
like my dad once told me i brought you
into this world and i will you know you
know the rest basically russian dead
it's okay different cultures but
basically uh what the thing you don't
understand stephen is that jerome powell
started off saying that this is that we
don't have inflation even though we
printed 40 percent of the us dollar
ever in the past year and then he went
and explained that
the problem is that we don't understand
what transitory is
it's not about
the transitioning of inflation up and
down it's us transitioning into the
realization that
we just have to
believe every word he says despite the
reality now finally
we're coming to the last stop the final
stop which is accidentally close to his
renomination of course i'm sure it has
nothing to do with the fact he got
renominated but
essentially now
he got renominated he gets to keep his
job which is good for him and now all of
a sudden uh he's basically saying well
you know i made a huge mistake basically
everything i told you in the past two
years was
everything is wrong and the i think it's
it's it's good wait hold on you're not
suggesting that jerome powell was saying
it's all transitory it's all fine while
he's being renominated and then as soon
as he's being renominated he suddenly
changes his language that's not what
you're suggesting no no god forbid this
would be the case i think it would take
a really cynical person to think
something like this of course uh
the thing you need to understand stephen
again you're as you being a cynical
person you're missing the whole point of
this is the point here is quite simple
jerome powell is basically telling you
right now listen i made a huge mistake
everything i've ever said
since the epidemic started until
yesterday which was before the the
hearing was complete nonsense and i
think it takes a really
a strong person to admit that he's been
so wrong for so long i think he should
be awarded for this in fact i should i
think we should give him the
congressional medal of honor for having
the balls to say that every hit he
stopped
i'm sure it has nothing to do with his
renomination i find it uh really
insulting that you would think that
stephen the thing about that really
plexus
it really perplexes me we should keep it
in
little bubbles coming out of my mouth
the thing that really perplexes me
stephen
is that in fact the data
that john powell is basing his
assumption on it hasn't really changed
it's basically the completely identical
the cpi which is the core price index
which is the fed's favorite metric to
measure inflation
which is in itself a little bit of a
cheat code because it doesn't really
look at housing and stock market which
is usually the more inflationary areas
of the economy is already at a 30-year
high the last time it was this high i
think the original bush was the
president or even clinton i don't even
remember it was long ago so the numbers
hasn't changed it's very structionary
low participation in the job market
very high core price index and all of a
sudden he sees something i think god
must have spoken to him bro this is the
only explanation i have because the
thing that hasn't changed god came down
and said jerome i think you were wrong
and i think he embraced this and good
for him for having the courage to
realize that he was wrong listen now let
me give you an example it's like going
to the doctor's and and giving him an
x-ray of your chest and the doctor is
looking at you and saying well
everything is fine your chest is you
know you're like a spanish bull and then
he calls you two weeks later said listen
i looked at it again and the
you're dying
this is exactly the same thing not that
the economy is dying but i mean this is
the same level of mistake that was made
here and i think it's it's a real
shine
it's a sign of honesty if federal
officials are willing to come out and
say how bad they are at their job i
think we should be commended for doing
that so one of the things that i've been
looking at is um just the amount of
positive coverage that's come out about
inflation there's been a lot of talk by
media outlets recently that there's no
need to panic because in fact not only
are high levels inflation maybe not even
happening but if they are happening at
all it's actually a good thing for poor
people and a bad thing for jeff bezos do
you think that's true that jeff bezos is
the one suffering and that uh his amazon
workers are the one who are going to be
liberated by inflation these are real
headlines i just just saw something from
the intercept i've seen something some
things from things like you know vox
where people are talking about look
inflation's not that big of a deal it's
actually good for you it's going to
lower your debts what do you think about
that i think it's rich people are saying
this to the poor people where while
they're getting off the titanic pretty
much it's very similar
and you and i are the band playing on
the boat while everybody is basically
saying to the poor
hey stay on the boat drowning is good
for you
this is this is the transitory sinking
curry dried
you'll come back better than ever if it
doesn't kill you make you stronger i
swear to god just stay stay here while
we get on the lifeboats it's it's
literally what's going on here because
listen to be involved seriousness this
is what's going on inflation erodes your
purchasing power inflation causes a
single dollar to be worth less a month
ago a year ago you could buy 10x
this time you can buy 3x you just lost a
[ __ ]
that you can't buy simple as that if
you're rich
3x is still a lot of x's but if you're
more than 3x it's not a lot of x's so by
definition and i've seen this with my
own eyes as a kid some of you may not
know this but i was a young kid in
russia when the russian influ
hyperinflation happened in the 90s and i
saw how people send their sell their
underwear and socks on the market this
improvised market just to get some food
and how uh you know a kilogram of apples
is now basically your monthly salary it
ain't pretty you think the richest
people felt the same amount of pain as
the poor people i mean it's preposterous
it's pretty much uh reminds me of the
story a long time ago when i came back i
was 16 17 years old came back from a
party very intoxicated my dad saw me and
i immediately said without him even
asking well i'm not drunk and he of
course said nothing but his eyes was
very telling and as i walked to my room
i immediately started to
lose
the the gravitational force lose to the
gravitational force essentially skewing
to the 45 degree angle all the way to
basically lying flat on the ground
while i was making my way to the room
essentially making it very clear what's
really going on here when i hear
mainstream media
push this narrative uh i'm much like my
dad in 1997 or whenever that was i just
i pity the fool i mean it's simple it's
just a bunch of googly goon nonsense so
what do you think the lifeboats are you
talked about people are getting on the
titanic
the lifeboat whatever what is that like
what does that analogy mean that analogy
is very simple there's a lot of asset
classes that are very good inflation to
protect your money
because they park your money at
certain areas of the economy that's
going to go up during inflation i don't
know if you notice but real estate is
hella expensive right now why do you
think that's happening because everybody
try try buy a house right now rather
just try and list the house
yeah everybody's buying up real estate
the problem is which is it's a really
good measure to counter inflation to
park your money in real estate the
problem is if you're a school teacher or
bus driver you can't really buy real
estate because you're living paycheck to
paycheck and once your paycheck is
realistically now worth one half of what
it was worth two years ago you're in dip
and ain't no amount of good publicity is
going to help you pay for your lunch no
no amount of uh articles are gonna
are gonna can they
no problem you can have this burger it
will be four and a half articles here
you go one cnn article three fox
articles and one cnbs article here you
go here's your burger sir
it's not gonna it's the only way bro
what do you think i mean obviously biden
wants to keep the party going uh that's
he's
he's kind of incentivized to you know
and every president is incentivized to
always every government is low
and always keep growth at all costs then
you have the fed coming in and saying
wait we need to do something different
who do you think is going to win this
little battle
so first of all we have to be clear
about it's a completely bipartisan thing
every government in any country does not
want the fed of its country the central
bank of its country to actually stop the
party right now
we have an example of what's going on
when the politics wins over the
economist of course all of you follow
the the turkish economy i'm sure every
single one of you is you know nope
yeah an avid viewer of what's gonna so i
don't know if you heard this but
in turkey just about two weeks ago uh
the the local currency which is called
the turkish lira so the turkish lira
crashed about 30 percent lost a third of
its value in just a few days why because
basically they have a guy over there
that calls the shots and they decided
well we're not going to raise interest
they don't have like an independent
central bank that can actually do it and
the economy is collapsing and you're
going to see some really harsh results
now the thing is
you have to understand despite all my
criticism uh either direct or indirect
or cynical in the us we still have this
independence the only point of of
non-independence we had is when biden
actually appointed or renominated john
paul for another term but once that
happened it's no longer in biden's hands
it's basically he has the job he can do
whatever he wants and he's actively
pursuing that to his credit what he said
in the latest hearing is 100 correct
they have to
stop asset purchases as fast as possible
and raise interest rates because right
now we're dealing with a junkie the u.s
market is a junkie in really bad shape
and they must go through rehab if we
have any chance of saving it and trust
me going through rehab isn't going to be
pretty isn't going to be nice it's going
to be painful but it has to be done so
to his credit and that's not cynical him
actually the latest testimony actually
sounds what he should have said like
about a year ago finally we're getting
this done
yeah i just looked at uh turkish lira
thing up it said uh i'm reading this is
from reuters 1005 the lyric recovered
after weakening to 1388 first the dollar
it touched an all-time low of 14 last
week after a 30 plunge over the last
month
so this is what you're saying is
what happens when you have too much just
nobody's basically paying attention to
how much money is being printed and
pumped into the economy you're just
trying to keep the party going but you
try to do it too long if let me let me
give you a simple example how i think
things played out the government wants a
long-term relationship with money
printing imagine it's tinder right and
the government is is looking for for
and jerome powell is on tinder basically
saying well i want a really long
relationship with the with the with
printing money as well they hook up and
then after they hook up john paul says
well nope and he blocks the government
from his focus it's literally what just
happened bro so uh i think it's a really
good analogy of what just happened
you're saying he just kind of he kind of
stiffed yeah he just ghosted bro he's he
goes to bed he goes he goes to bite it
obviously biden wouldn't have
renominated him had he known that
powell was going to just like tighten
things up no no no i think
it would be very hard for me of course
to
claim that there is a relationship
between the biden and john paul but i
think like on a more economic level i
think that relationship
would not have gone forward
had biden thought that
paul is going to pull the stunt which he
just did on in front of the congress
basically saying well the party's over
and he's doing it right in front of just
before christmas which is probably the
worst time for a politician to start
tapering yeah right because everyone
wants to go out there get their
christmas gifts not worry about the
economy
yeah it seems like we're it's really
interesting to see the times we're
living in with this like sort of
unprecedented monetary policy so i guess
there's so much that i don't know here i
guess what what should people be looking
for just your average
average con person out there works a
nine to five job you know he's looking
at this he's wondering what's going on
obviously we don't give financial advice
on the show but what are your thoughts
as just someone who watches the markets
yeah i think it's a good time to
er to to stay away from the stock market
a little bit if you haven't dipped your
feet in in the stock market now it's
probably not a good time because you
have to understand that the byproduct of
what the fed is about to institute right
now which is a major policy shift
essentially you know stopping the money
printer stopping basically the asset
purchases is essentially stopping the
money printer and raising interest rates
is pretty much you know clubbing the
economy with the club until submission
that whole process is going to have an
immense impact on the stock market it
doesn't really matter right now how it's
going to work but essentially the
elevated interest rate is going to push
most of the u.s stocks
way down
and the most of the pain will be for the
speculative stocks the small caps the
the ones that don't really make a lot of
money now and they have a really huge
upside in the future explain that a
little bit break that down a little bit
okay so why is this the case okay i'll
explain when
in finance when you evaluate a company
how would you evaluate the company you
look at their cash flows right how much
money can i get from this company if
you're buying a business
that's the first question you ask right
how much how much revenue you have every
year how much profit you have every year
and you say okay so how much money will
this company make for the next 10 years
and you use different assumptions
basically say okay how much the revenues
will grow or not grow every year how
much the expenses would grow every year
and you come up to a certain number like
a cash flow a projected cash flow for
the next 10 years but you know if i tell
you right now well stephen you owe me a
million dollar in 2035 and you tell
people tom i'm willing to pay you today
in 2021 how much would you take to get
rid of of this debt and then i'll
probably tell you probably like give me
500 000 today and you don't have to give
me the million in 2035. the same thing
happens in the stock market now that
difference between the million to the
500 is determined by the level of
interest because that level of interest
is what's the weighted average cost of
capital and as the way the average cost
of capital will go up eventually once
they raise interest rates it's going to
push all these valuations down because
the bringing these cash flows from year
10 all the way back to 2021 is going to
become more expensive essentially
lowering every single valuation of every
single company in the stock market right
so prices of stocks go down we enter
perhaps i'll give an example a better
example you know the commercials for the
for the guy who
like i want my annuity now i forgot his
name and there's the people the singing
it's like the jerry finally
[Music]
he'll basically give you a lump sum
today and he'll buy you and it is off
you the the amount you get now basically
gets slashed massively once the interest
rate goes up the same thing with company
valuations because company valuations
are essentially annuities if you really
think about it so i guess my question is
this tom to sort of wrap this up where
do you think the u.s is headed now that
we're gonna probably see uh rates change
them try to control inflation which is
going to kind of stop the party a little
bit what do you think is gonna happen is
this gonna be
a recession not to be a michael bury or
a peter schiff here where we're calling
those guys the doomsday forecasters all
the time it's kind of never really works
so i'm not trying to forecast anything
but where do you think the general
trajectory is by the way shout out to
michael berry for successfully
predicting five out of the last zero
stock market crashes
just kidding i love michael berry one of
the best in the business so i think it's
a necessary beating the market has to
take
it's it's honestly
the thing the only choice the fed
actually has you have to commend
honestly john paul for actually doing
this now i think it's gonna be painful
it's gonna be unpleasant like any rehab
we have to go through it and eventually
we're gonna come out stronger i know
there's this thing in the u.s as a
foreigner i find it amusing how
self-deprecating americans are to their
own country and economy everything is
going to be fine it's going to be
unpleasant it's going to be a little bit
painful um but eventually i would not
bet against the u.s economy bro it's
going to be just fine
usa
hey
thank you so much for coming by that way
to end it off strong guys if you guys
want to go follow tom nash
on youtube
show um
thanks for watching everybody